vanessa vous êtes né en 1972 à saint
maur des fossés votre père andré était
président directeur général d'une
miroiterie joliment dit mais d'une
miroiterie faisait des et poutres en
polyuréthane abondamment et avait des
miroirs dont ceux des poutres apparentes
en polyuréthane et votre mère corinne
était directrice de société c'est ça
elle a été un peu plus tard j'avais une
tombe comptable dans l'associé des
parents très uni non je dis ça parce que
vous avez des parents très uni 30 ans
que ça vous sert de modèle vous oui pour
monter numéros attribués dès l'âge de 4
ans ont pris des cours de piano et de
danse rythmique et vous monter des
petits spectacles est alors un jour
votre oncle le comédien didier pain
remarque que votre joli brin de voix et
vous propose enfin proposer à vos
parents que vous fassiez de l'école des
fans voilà votre première apparition à
la télévision
oui enfin c'est simple c'est plus sain
que ça c'est mon oncle et il sait que je
rêve de chanter que les communes et
musical c'est tout ce qui me fait rêver
et et que comme les enfants de à
l'époque de mon âge regarde à l'école
des fans et et j'adorais la comédie
musicale emilie jolie et se trouve
qu'ils avaient fini chatel qui faisait
les missions et bien on est mais c'était
pas le il était pas producteur à
l'époque c'était pour faire plaisir
sanef l époque où dix huit ans et quand
j'avais 10 ans fait un 45 tours en
association avec les forbans qui
s'appelle la magie des surprises parties
que vous avez fait intervenir le
prouvent puces dites moi je les chercher
je ne trouve pas c'est un collector si
quelqu'un l'a mois
pourquoi vous voulez plus qu'ils sortent
parce que j'ai je n'aime pas beaucoup et
se trouve que je l'avais enregistré à 10
ans et comme j'avais 13 ans il était
toujours pas sortis entre 10 et 16 ans
là la voix elle change suis surtout les
les goûts et les envies changent donc
j'avais plus envie de faire ça puis le
disque est jamais sorti et puis moment
où joe le taxi est sorti là comme par
hasard il est certain en tout les cas
vanessa c'est grâce à cette chanson que
vous rencontrez franck langolff lors de
l'enregistrement de la maquette de
l'album de sophie marceau c'est
saintonge et aller pour voir que vous la
voyez chanter dans le studio est
derrière la vitre qui vous dit quand
même c'est pas terrible
il préfère dit pourquoi pas moi comme
l'embryon
en plus j'y suis allé à l'époque au
studio parce que j'adorais sophie
marceau à l'époque
aujourd'hui vous avez fait cinq albums
cinq films et votre dernier film c'est
de tomber complètement à lola cette
histoire de don quichotte là c'est
horrible cette histoire non c'était dur
on est enfin au moment où ça s'est passé
puisque jean rochefort a dû se faire
opérer ont été pour lui un film
s'appelle l'homme qui a tué don
quichotte de terry gilliam qui est un
grand réalisateur donc avec vous avec
johnny depp jean rochefort dans le rôle
de effectivement de don quichotte le
deuxième jour le plateau est inondé le
quatrième jour guillian découvre que le
paysage a changé de couleur etc il est
pur accord et qu'il faut tout refaire
le cinquième jour c'est horrible
l'assistant découvre que rochefort peut
pas tourner ils se disputent il tente
quand même il faut trois personnes pour
le faire descendre de cheval et le
sixième jour il a évacué sur sur paris
le tournage est interrompu et vous après
votre de trucs à faire vous avez votre
tournée et puis j'imagine que johnny
depp il a aussi des engagements et le
projet est abandonné il n'aura jamais on
verra jamais ce film est question ça
vous touche moins qu'avant ce genre de
trucs depuis que vous êtes mère de
famille vous allez appeler votre album
bichon ce que dira féliciter vous dit
finalement on pouvait toujours divisés
mais pas beaucoup qu'on parle de votre
vie privée dans la presse et la
télévision et là dans cet album bliss
vous parlait que de ça c'est un peu
contradictoire non d'une certaine façon
well peut-être mais je ne raconte pas de
détails je parle de sujets universels
qui est qui qui concerne enfin une
grande partie des femmes ouais c'est
cécilia pas il n'y a pas de détail a pas
de deux ne s'est pas un journal intime
et puis c'était la première fois que
j'écrivais des chansons que j'avais
envie de parler des des gens et des
choses que j'aime le plus elle est loin
l'époque de saba
las une chanson florent pagny à l'époque
vous étiez ensemble vous avez tellement
de problèmes avec les paparazzi qui
avait fait cette chanson a pas les
paparazzis la presse ipi crise qui est
be quiet princes paris je vais souffert
de sa l'époque ni un pack vous croyez
que ce n'est pas du tout cette pression
de la presse votre couple aurait pu
continuer annonce s alors vous êtes
attiré par les stars ou c'est simplement
parce que vous voyez des stars dans
votre milieu parce que finalement j'ai
toujours été avec des gens assez connue
fait maintenant la couche donné du tout
saïd sur le foyer de la sonacotra ya
deux projets tablier mais oui parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas demain mais oui non
sérieusement vous étés et florent pagny
lenny kravitz et rien de ce qui arrivera
il va venir en parler voire maire de
leur histoire star c'est pas c'est
comment dire c'est pas c'est pas une
qualité c'est pas non plus un métier
avant d'être star on est star parce que
parce que on fait de la musique où on
écrit des livres où on n'est pas où on
est star de deux boulangeries
mais quand on aime quelqu'un et qu'on
met à tirer par quelqu'un c'est c'est
pour tout ce qu'ils représentent et
l'homme que j'aime aujourd'hui c'est une
star mais avant d'être une star
c'est quelqu'un qui fait des choses que
j'admire forcément ça et jour quelque
chose des sims est plus épanouie au
départ en plus parce qu'il avait quand
même une réputation super houleuse nom
super difficile je ne sais pas c'est
quelqu'un de c'est quelqu'un de juste et
qui réagit quand tu y es quand ils
continueraient à agir agressivement
comme on a pu voir ça quelquefois c'est
toujours pour une bonne raison
en tout cas de mes raisons que je dans
les situations que j'ai vécue celle
d'avant je sais pas mais mais c'est vrai
c'est tout à fait les choses comme quand
il était avec winona ryder ou kate moss
il se battait toujours où il était
toujours très agressif depuis qu'il
avait vu ses prix vous avez calme et
festive
non je vais pas calmé moi il est lisse
et qu'elle met tout seul mon fils mais
quand quand ils scott ce genre
d'événements sont on en parle dans la
presse on a l'impression que c'est
arrivé 50 fois alors si c'est arrivé une
fois mais comme on le répète 50 fois
l'impression que ça arrive tout le temps
c'est un secret tête mais non non je
sais j'ai lu ça quelque fois et j'ai
comme si je l'avais donc t'es où j'ai
rien fait il a fait tout seul le dompter
sans rien faire là il est au pied en
tous les cas vous avez un enfant qui
s'appelle donc lily rose melody
ça va vous êtes besoin de personnes tous
les trois là tout va bien vous êtes dans
votre maison dans le midi tous assez
calme ses eaux
pourquoi passer ou pas ce n'est pas ma
route pour qu'ils me disaient ressentir
au club breton a ouvert presque envie
que je vienne
c'est bien d'avoir risqué est-ce que
vous allez vous marier
nous non c'est pas qu'on parle pas trop
j'en sais rien on n'en parle pas vous en
parlez pas encore là on en parle on en
parle pas ça s'est passé pas quelque
chose qui nous qui nous paraît important
pour l'instant faire un enfant c'est ce
que vous dites je ne suis pas la
meilleure chanteuse du monde je ne suis
pas la meilleure actrice du monde mais
c'est tombé sur moi
des cadeaux du ciel oui beaucoup de
cadeau du ciel alors j'ai en même temps
je travaille quand même ça c'est ça
s'est nourri cette l'itif tout ça mais
j'ai beaucoup de cadeaux beaucoup de
chance donc quand on fait une entame
très sérieuses et c'est l'interview
expliqué à ma fille en la bouche pendant
le king a raté
plus
votre fille vous demande maintenant
pourquoi on meurt en corner ce qu'il ya
dans les ca et un début un milieu et une
fin
et puis il faut bien que ça s'arrête
sont au bout d'un moment on devient
complètement à la ramasse ya la cuillère
mais après il ya autre chose surtout je
dirais ça sert à quoi de travailler
puisqu'il suffit d'aller à la machine
pour prendre de l'argent
baa à occuper ses journées et a mangé
mon père est dit c'est le taxi de la
liberté
l'argent mais j'aime bien cette
expression ce taxi csat récurrents la
famille argent maman c'est quoi ce que
vous mettez dans vos cigarettes avec
papa
amélie et non j'aime explique pour
l'instant soit 6 du tabac ça va il n'y a
pas de problème pas de problème non mais
de toute façon j'ai jugé lui expliquerai
je préfère hawijah monsieur préfère
c'est qu'ils puissent passer les
frontières tranquille avait huit kilos
aussi aux états unis et moi pourquoi
papa il a fait un baiser sur la bouche à
la baby sitter
bagis tirait mais parce que parce qu'ils
l'aiment bien qui voulait lui dire
bonjour
après 50 balles de leurs on peut quand
même temps un bisou quoi maman pourquoi
en tentant mois la radio en ce moment
parce que parce que les gens les aiment
pas trop méchants sont en ce moment et
dit maman qu'est la question qui n'a pas
de réponse c'est chiant les gosses c'est
pourquoi pourquoi je t'aime pas de
réponse c'est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
mais si vanessa paradis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me sens
c'est vrai que ça faisait un moment ça
faisait un moment qu'on n'avait pas vu
une vanessa paradis
on est très heureux très heureux de
pouvoir donner ça alors lors de notre
première rencontre c'était en 1987
c'était aux bains douches l'émission
s'appelait bain de minuit
c'était l'année de joe le taxi et les
paroles de la chanson était d' etienne
roda-gil magnéto serge alors la petite
fille vanessa comet a vendu de disques
est une scène un patron ou pas loin d'un
million de serfs quelqu'un de le lier
aux valeurs de ce monde après chaque
mois tu peux le chantait joe sexy or tu
vas pas de chanter en espagnol
aussi je rechante instaurons passé ce
soir voilà c'est fait diminuer en 1985
avec julien clerc etienne roda-gil
vanessa paradis
étienne roda-gil qui nous a quittés
récemment et pour qui je voudrais qu'on
est une une pensée parce que c'est
quelqu'un de tout à fait important pour
nous et et pour vous rire du commun
vraiment un type exceptionnel
on n'a pas dit si au moment où vous ça
s'est passé parce que c'était comme ça
et ce soir je suis ravi de lui rendre
hommage en votre compagnie vanessa
etienne
si tu ne regarde comme une rigueur
validité regarde arte qui les tiennent
ouais ah oui bien sûr il arrive ce soir
vanessa après cinq ans d'absence cinéma
donc le temps de faire deux enfants lily
rose et jack le temps d'un cd qui
s'appelle bliss et d'une tournée vous
revenez dans un film absolument barjots
une comédie de science-fiction qui
s'appelle atomik circus le retour de
james bataille des frères poireau alors
c'est un film ovni ascain c'est
complètement un pitch à bhl c'est une
série z déjanté ça se passe dans un
village qui s'appelle scott lake city un
village rétro-futuriste donc au fin fond
des usa où on prépare une grande fête
c'est la fête de la tarte à la vache
avec une chanteuse qui s'appelle quantya
c'est vous et un cascadeur qui s'appelle
james bataille voilà alors dès son
arrivée james bataille séduit concha qui
veut devenir chanteuse
poussé par son père le patron du bar qui
est joué par jean-pierre marielle voilà
mais la fête se termine en catastrophe à
paris et parallèlement un météorite
s'écrase sur scott let libérant
d'étranges choses volante gens les
pieuvres des pierres volante avait comme
dans les films américains des années 50
et la démarque
l'imprésario alan chiasse joué par
benoît poelvoorde
qui drague vanessa c'est un petit chat
c'est bien ce que je disais c'est un
mini est lorsque je propose d'abord
avant toute chose mais ça c'est que vous
regardiez votre caméra et que vous dites
magnéto serge on va voir à quoi ça
ressemble ici c'est insensé ce film
quand vous avez reçu le scénario vous
avez réagi comme en ait beaucoup ri
ouais beaucoup ri essayer de remettre
les palmes dans l'ordre c'est vrai
qu'ils avaient pas mal des choses
incompréhensibles et fin des choses pas
très claires mais il y avait un le ton
qui a dans le film était déjà dans le
scénario le la bande démo des frères
poireau qui avait fait beaucoup de pub
et des courts métrages et des clips
étaient vraiment un sens c'est très très
très original et puis eux c'est des gars
sont bourrés de talent est tellement
sincère et j'ai très fier d'être de
faire partie de ce film qui a été fait
en france par des français avec des
acteurs presque tous français et vash
est fier alors les frères poireau
effectivement ce sont les nantais 1 et
ils ont fait appel pour la musique à
doutre nantais qui s'appelle les petits
lapins des little rabbits il ya une
chanson qui est très drôle c'est la
pétroleuse
[Applaudissements]
à
orlando orlando nous lui parlons nous il
va pas nous faire chier l'année
prochaine non plus aux landes où il
commença bien casser les couilles quand
même bon orlando exige le clip ma m 20
[Musique]
map être le serbe a fait
ouais voilà
dany chantal a dit avec les petits
enfants
ça s'appelle m'a fait trop alors
[Applaudissements]
vénizélos michael berrer
m
non
je tiens à vous et vous seuls
c'est le coup de la loi
voix
3 thierry ça arrive parfois je crois que
les gens le public n'accroche pas que
cette chanson non
c'est pas la peine de s'acharner on est
appelés ta j'aime dans la chanson c'est
comme ça qu'est ce que tu veux pas ici
c'est les endroits de le faire alors le
disque sort chez barclays ce qui veut
dire que contrairement aux rumeurs qui
ont couru
vous n'êtes pas viré de chez barclays
ils ont fait l'autre chez barclays ouais
ceci est en ce moment vous semblez
préféré vanessa paradis votre carrière
d'actrice à votre carrière de chanteuse
8 le cinéma c'est les vacances de la
personnalité on devient quelqu'un
d'autre on est très entourée c'est vrai
alors que chanteuse
c'est d'une extrême solitude j'en ai un
peu je préfère pas je ne préfère pas et
c'est là les projets la ville ça se
présente comme ça et puis je met plus de
temps à faire les chansons maintenant
parce que je je les fais un petit peu
moins avec l'aide d'autres personnes et
donc ça me prend dr ce que j'essaie de
factures icc l'on vous dit je ne suis
pas gainsbourg et puis les enfants
prennent beaucoup de temps
c'est moi qui vais prendre beaucoup de
temps avec mes enfants parce que je n'ai
rien envie de louper ses revenus élevés
vous-même quoi enfin je suis allé faire
élever par d'autres préfèrent les élevez
vous même
alors question cinéma quand même vous
venez de tourner avec le scénariste de
la fille sur le pont qui s'appelle serré
manqué qui a réalisé son premier film
huawei est un petit bijou et c'est
encore quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup qui
a écrit et qui écrit une histoire
sublimer je viens juste de finir de le
tourner donc c'est encore assez frais
avec un jeune acteur qui s'appelle
vincent rottiers il faut retenir soit
parce que c'est une une bombe atomique
une perle règles à 17 ans et il sait pas
ce que tu as son portable à vincent
rottiers un attaché de presse
on va demander qu'il l'appelle pas
l'inviter tout de suite alors en tous
les cas si on peut dire vanessa c'est
vous fait pas d'effort particulier pour
tournée en amérique ou dj aucune
ambition internationale vous ai même pas
d'agent hollywood
non non non pourquoi mais parce que je
feins ils ont déjà ils ont des gens très
très bien ils ont pas franchement besoin
de me crois qu'ils ont besoin nous
sommes à moins que ce soit un projet
enfin quelque chose de spécial mais
faire la course au projet j'ai
l'impression que tout le temps est là
moi qui tourne quand même une fois tous
les 36 du mois la banque pourrait
tourner tout le temps pour jamais quand
vous oublie pied parce que j'ai
franchement jules moi j'ai tout ce qu'il
me faut ici en france puis j'ai un peu
plus l'europe pourquoi je voyage je n'ai
pas déjà ça me prend beaucoup de temps
mais s'il fallait en plus que je fasse
ça là bas puis c'est bien là bas on ne
montre pas du doigt
si vous êtes sages pénalement dans c'est
pas ouais six mois si elle élève ses
enfants elle veut pas faire la course à
hollywood
vous êtes assez sage mais je suis très
normal c'est très ennuyeux c'est bien
non pas du tout enfin je sais pas ce
qu'en pense votre johnny depp mais moi
personnellement je trouve ça bien
il avait l'air de se plaindre
apparemment fait longtemps que cet
ensemble soit quand même temps si c'est
bien déjà et vous michel depuis combien
de temps et votre femme
trois mois alors vous avez passé
- looser maison
ça va commencer les premiers mois c'est
les plus durs michel nous irons ensemble
depuis trois mois
oui sommes pas mariés encore un 3 - et
les noces de bistrot non
vanessa est toujours pas mariés n'ont
plus jamais ça j'ai des enfants alors
vanessa vous n'avez toujours pas de
projet avec johnny depp qui a eu cette
histoire de don quichotte pour laquelle
nous avons reçu jean rochefort ici
l'année dernière pour la sortie du dvd
bon aventure avortée terrible histoire
évidemment et c'est vrai qu'après le
succès de pirates des caraïbes qui a
fait quand même 621 millions de dollars
de recettes énormes
la suite est déjà en chantier donc lui
voilà il est happé par ça et on fait
effectivement vous concentrer sur votre
rôle de maman surtout à los angeles où
vous passez votre temps entre les cours
de danse pour les enfants les ateliers
d'arts plastiques pour les enfants
le pédiatre pour les enfants et le pas
sur les enfants et un poney club là bas
mais c'est bien mais comme tout le monde
sait pas si vous pouviez de la coke au
queen tous les soirs on vous
féliciteraient car voilà maintenant
alors entre deux tournages vous avez
votre maison avec johnny depp dans le
sud de la france nous reposer un petit
peu voilà la drees qui
mais une déviation d'ax et pour 10
achetés légalement oui alors vous dites
on va au marché en cuisinant mangent ils
ont une vie terriblement simple vous
vivez une espèce de bohème très chic un
petit peu comme dans les années 70 c'est
rockstar d'idées comme ça quand vous
voyagez avec johnny d'alger comme 30
valise qui vous suivent que j'ai quand
même c'est pas d'arrêt en voyage mais
celle aussi où que des fringues les
meubles non par exemple j'étais donne un
exemple oran le drap qui recouvre la
table a longé par exemple n'est pas
important que les enfants soient
habitués la couleur du drap vanessa
prend ce drap tu vas là c'est tout ça
c'est vrai ah c'est beau quand vous
dites ça mais non mais aussi parce que
moi j'en les enfants et vivent une vie
de bohème mais bon là c'est vrai qu'on
leur a pas tellement de demander leur
avis ne sont pas l'air de s'en plaindre
mais il faut quand même pas les jeux
l'échangé de maison sans arrêt sans
qu'ils aient des choses ici qu'ils
reconnaissent qu a pour patron vanessa
paradis et johnny depp ch et un couple
parfait
c'est le bonheur absolu donc on va faire
une interview je fous la merde
[Musique]
lessard est toujours amoureuse de johnny
depp n'est toujours pas mariés donc vous
serez pas qu'il est un peu moins bon ce
moment c'était faux non c'est vrai qu'il
a une vilaine verrues plantaires
c'est un dommage d'être tout le temps
séparés non sérieux justement n'a pas
tout le temps c'est vrai il néglige pas
là non c'est caen qui vous a dit je
t'aime pour la dernière fois vous avez
cadeau qui vous a fait c'est quoi
je sais pas si j'ai vachement
attentionné quand ils offrent des fleurs
il dit pas sa secrétaire de le faire
c'est lui qui va vraiment les achetés au
magasin il n'oublie jamais votre
anniversaire
tu veux te rends compte non plus non
merci l'internet pour savoir si les
parcelles moi je vous le confirme tout
de suite les îles éparses mais parfois
quand même bien sûr ils oublient de
relever la cuvette des toilettes
non jamais menacé un mec formidable non
sérieusement c'est quoi qui vous énerve
le plus chez lui qu'on ne fasse pas nous
il a des défauts mais je voulais mais il
est pardonné il laisse traîner ses
chaussettes
bah ouais mais j'aimerais pas qui
arrange tout c'est à prague ont pu
nommer vous êtes on va dire il a un
petit peu un tempérament de feu
ouais et qui sait pas toujours très
facile mais mais mais moi ça me plaît
quand même à ses qui à l'eau vincent
rottiers salut c'est laurent bâti tué
sur paris là il peut passer
oui bonjour vincent 20 tel qu on est à
l'antenne tu es sur paris est ce que tu
peux passer s'il te plaît à la plaine
saint denis
c'est vanessa matz d'une ans et vanessa
paradis qui a parlé de toi l'addict
était formidable et je te la patiente
maneval qu on t'attend
moi aussi je t'embrasse je te passe
vanessa à l'eau non mais si toi
non mais c'est mais oui je suis pour
rien j'ai juste voulu dire des jeux
d'hiver alors alors quand en plus c'est
un idée de venir
mais non ils veulent que tu n'en vient
pas dire faction devant leur télé
[Applaudissements]
au moment où il ya plein mon nom mais il
a mieux à faire il à la fête de la
musique c'est ça c'est bien cette
semaine tandis que la faille à gré des
deux papes amoureuse de lui mais j'ai
beaucoup de tendresse pour lui cela
devait arriver c'est bien et c'est ainsi
pas sonné samedi a pu la fête de la
musique c'est le dollar qui vient à
l'est avec vanessa le tas d'or jusqu'à
johnny depp jeu serait jaloux mois elle
tu adores l avis de la 18 balles étaient
hyper mignon elle a dit m il venait
d'avoir 18 ans elle a même chanté enfin
il vit que c'est une belle aventure avec
toi mais qui passe de minutes à nous
raconter bon tout à l'heure on t'attend
je crois qu'il a passés que de mettre
les choses au point
alors
deux des trois petites questions
diverses donc il est parfait si johnny
depp évidemment il râle pas quand il
faut descendre la poubelle non les
rallyes
il a des mamies qui vous énerve quand
même oh là là quand même bien a quand
même à vous l'avez déjà chopé en train
de regarder un film porno non non bon
ben c'est sans espoir
[Musique]